des mecs ils arrivent à avoir une
attitude de beau gosse en toutes
circonstances ce qui me rend pas
spécialement jaloux fort le beau gosse
c'est un leader
s'ils se lève pour partir tout le monde
le suit au niveau des gares alors si
c'est lui qui décide alors que moi quand
j'ai envie de partir le beau gosse quand
il se déshabille pour pour faire l'amour
il est sauvage excuse moi les choses ça
veut dire que le mec à chaque fois
qu'ils se déshabille il détruit une
chemise moi je préfère ma méthode à moi
j'ai pas su et dans donc je vais la
remettre demain
le beau gosse quand ils l'abordent une
fille même s'ils utilisent la phrase
d'accroché la plus banale du monde ça
fonctionne je peux payer un verre mois
les seules fois où j'ai essayé d'aborder
une meuf avec ce genre de phrase j'avais
juste l'impression d'être un gros
pervers
je bois de l'alcool avec moi bon certes
plein place que moi j'ai pas de mercure
google vient mois vient boire dépôt le
beau gosse quand il est au restaurant et
qui choisit un vin ici connaît je vais
prendre un certain millions souplet 96
mois le 20 je choisis au hasard
mais si le serveur me fais goûter en
ouvrant la bouteille je fais quand même
genre de me connaître un petit peu pas
mal mais c'est bien ça même si c'est pas
vrai excusez moi en fait du shampoing
95,3 me trompais ah ah bah ouais je me
dis c'est bien ça c'est pas une bonne
année ça 95
ouais d'ailleurs le beau gosse quand il
boit du vin rouge
il est classe moi quand je bois du vin
rouge ça fait cet effet là les beaux
gosses quand les arrivants boîte ils
connaissent le videur même pas il se
pose la question de savoir s'ils vont
rentrer dans la boîte on est 45
reda mais alors aucune consigne de vote
ce week end j'aimerais trouve être pote
avec un videur alors à chaque fois quand
je passe devant je fais ce genre d'être
cool salut ça va aller ça va pas être
possible tout soit ok c'est pas grave
paquet compote à plus tard le beau gosse
quand il se promène dans la rue et que
sa copine et que des mecs l'embrouillé
il réagit comme ça a commenté bonne foi
qui est la fraîcheur à bercy et les mecs
comme moi on parle à ma copine la sese
seko c'est quoi ces manières 1 vous
calmer hockey j'aime mieux ça c'est
marie beney tu as pris ton bonnet
je lui ai donné moi aussi moi aussi
quand ça m'arrive je suis pareil trop ne
regarde pas les regarde pas et pour pas
répond pas ne te laisse pas à la hauteur
ce cap et trois en cours le beau gosse
dans une soirée c'est le mec qui te sort
une guitare sèche et qui te mets une
pure ambiance en une seconde
[Musique]
et ça va c'est bon c'est juste une
guitare ça va moi aussi je sais jouer
d'un instrument ok c'était quand il pète
trop son slip remix le beau gosse à la
piscine tu le repère facilement
c'est le seul mec qui rentre dans l'eau
en moins d'une demi seconde et en
général comme ça elle est fille et les
bonnes bas à la piscine quand j'entre
dans l'eau c'est plutôt comme ça n'est
pas chaude chaude
je vais doucement parce que j'ai mangé
il ya pas longtemps là donc faut que je
fasse attention à l'hydrocution un beau
gosse ça c'est réparé une voiture je
veux dire les meuf elle kiffe parce que
c'est viril seuil et démarrer voir
est ce que je pensais c'est les bougies
qui était encrassé je sais même pas
faire la première étape de la réparation
c'est où le bouton pour ouvrir le capot
c'est celui-là c'est pas ça s'est passé
à temps le beau gosse même pour rentrer
dans sa voiture il a du charisme
moi j'aimerais trop comme dans starsky
hutch rentrer dans une décapotable sans
ouvrir la portière mais bon il faut une
décapotable quoi moi je suis moche pas
un beau gosse comme ça je sais pas faire
moi je manque mais je m'en fout en fait
moi j'ai moi j'ai d'autres talents
c'est bon j'ai trouvé une solution
[Musique]